Oh this wednesday the secrets of the multiverse
will be revealed oh i'm counting on it
ponder the question
follow me enter the multiverse
of infinite possibilities
where the stories you thought you
knew are nothing like you remember
it is our only chance
the red skull wants to destroy our
world i say we return the favor what if
captain carter was the first avenger
reality is not a straight line every
passing moment is a chance for a new
offshoot a new variation in fact there are
more realities than you can possibly fathom
an infinite number of what ifs i'm jeffrey wright
and as the voice of the watcher and marvel's what
if i can see what few others can the totality
of the multiverse across all time and space
the stories you thought you knew are nothing
like you remember and foes who became friends
uh wow i did not see that coming
Welcome back everyone happy what if week there's
a whole bunch of new trailer footage we'll
break down a bunch of easter eggs also explain
what's going on with thanos because obviously
things are radically different in all these
alternate universes that we're going to see
is part of this big multiverse plot also what's
going on with thor doctor strange some of the
other big characters so if you're brand new to the
channel i'm doing videos for all the episodes my
full episode one video is going to post tomorrow
that's right we're finally getting episodes also
do a giveaway for disney plus memberships all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and just leave all your predictions for the series
on the video just to explain what the vibe is and
how things connect at least at the beginning
of the series and then how they changed that
later in the series the series is meant to be
canon to the mcu and some of these characters
from the alternate universes will eventually show
up in live action like they've been talking about
captain carter being one of the biggest ones to
show up in live action eventually but there'll be
more characters beyond her if the producer says
that any of the twists that you see in episodes
any of the alternate versions of characters can
eventually get their own live-action spin-off
series like it's all up for grabs there are no
limits but if you've never read the what if comic
book series each of the episodes at least at the
beginning of this series deals with a different
alternate universe so like for instance the
universe the timeline where peggy carter winds
up becoming captain carter a version of captain
britain is a different universe from the universe
where black panther becomes a version of star-lord
which is also going to be a different universe
that they visit during episode 3 for instance
and it's the watcher that connects everything
as if he's watching all these alternate
timelines and alternate realities play out
it's really not till later in the series that the
different universe characters start to cross over
and they start to hype up the idea of the
guardians of the multiverse they're sort of
multiverse avengers team or the exiles if you're
a big comic book fan like in the later trailer
footage you see a version of dark doctor strange
like dormammu strange however you want to call him
working with a version of party thor you see
the mirror the avengers assemble moment but it's
the guardians of the multiverse and it's all the
different versions of the characters like you have
the version of killmonger that becomes black
panther with a version of black panther that
became star-lord a version of gamora in thanos
armor with his weapons so actually just to explain
what's going on with thanos because he doesn't
show up during a lot of this trailer footage but
he is a big part of the episodes in the series
because he's such a huge mcu character and this
is all about showing you what would happen if a
few things changed and maybe it shouldn't come
as a surprise but episode two is the black panther
becoming star-lord episode what if black panther
was taken by yondu instead of peter quill and
that winds up radically altering the history of
the universe in ways you couldn't possibly imagine
the whole thing with the version of thanos that's
showing up during the series at least at first the
first version of thanos is is what if thanos had
actually turned good what if he abandoned his
plan to erase half of all life in the universe
so when i say that black panther becoming
star-lord has huge consequences for the universe
that's one of them and they did clarify why yondu
winds up picking him up in wakanda instead of
picking peter quill up as a child in 1988 it's
all because of a mix-up so it's not because
black panther's mother slept with ego the living
planet so ego the living planet in the black
panther episode is not his father they didn't
want to get that spicy but the whole idea is
that t'challa is a child looks up at the stars
and just wants to see the world beyond wakanda
like he just wants to go explore the galaxy yondu
and the ravagers have a big mix-up so instead of
picking peter quill up like they were supposed
to they go to wakanda and they pick up t'challa
thinking mistakenly that he is ego the living
planet's child for the most part he gets peter
quill's backstory growing up with the ravagers
yondu still becomes his surrogate father names
him star-lord and you see them follow a slightly
different version of the plot of the guardians of
the galaxy movie in present day with a slightly
different version of the ravagers because of what
happened in the alternate timeline where black
panther was star-lord so this is where we get
back to the thanos of it all so in this timeline
thanos turns good abandons his plan to erase half
of all life becomes a ravager and winds up getting
teased a lot about it by all of his new comrades
like a racing half of all life that would make you
a psychopath that's genocide like mass genocide
killing all those people in that timeline gamora
still winds up being his adopted daughter they
still have their very contentious father-daughter
relationship but the way they explain is that
because his life played out the exact same up to
the events just before the guardians of the galaxy
movies he still had been going around one planet
at a time trying to erase half of all life so the
way she became his adopted daughter is still the
same it's not really till the late 80s when yondu
winds up picking t'challa up by mistake and he
becomes star-lord in the mid-90s as he starts
to grow up with the ravagers and they go around
the galaxy that the timeline really starts to
diverge up to the present day of the guardians of
the galaxy movies where you see thanos and gamora
and all these different versions of the characters
and the whole idea that black panther star-lord's
version of the ravagers is still a group of people
that goes around stealing from the rich and giving
to the poor robin hood style like a slightly less
dirtbag version of the ravagers than you see in
guardians of the galaxy one and two also because
they're doing the whole what if thanos became
good you have the idea that basically ultron winds
up replacing thanos as sort of avengers infinity
war level boss assembling the infinity gauntlet
or becoming himself a living infinity gauntlet
because all the infinity stones are embedded in
him he doesn't need to wear a gauntlet the other
joke about peter quill during that black panther
episode is that you see him working in the dairy
queen which has a whole lot of ant-man energy
baskin-robbins always finds out but the joke is
is that in the midwest at least during this time
in history dairy queen was the biggest ice cream
chain like there wasn't a lot of baskin robbins in
the midwest at that time and peter quill is from
missouri all the captain carter peggy carter stuff
we're going to see tomorrow during episode one
the whole idea what if she became a version
of captain america but because she's british
she's part of the british army she becomes the
version of captain britain so to speak that's
why she has all the union jack flair they actually
changed the captain america official twitter from
falcon's version of captain america to represent
captain carter for the duration of her episode and
some of the series they will change the twitter
account back to the falcon captain america for
the live-action movies eventually this is just a
gimmick that they're doing for the what-if series
right now but we do finally get some footage of
red skull with the tesseract and we see peggy
carter talking about how he wants to destroy the
world which sort of ties in with the idea of this
tentacle creature that looks like it came from a
doctor strange movie coming through a tesseract
portal red skull's whole plan in the original
captain america movie was that he just wanted
to conquer the planet not destroy the planet it
sounds like this version of red skull that we
see during the series as things go down a little
bit differently the timeline changes because what
happens with peggy carter just gets a little more
high on himself in the power of the infinity stone
the space stone and the tesseract so things really
start to go off the rails with the way he uses it
but in the way that you see captain carter here
meeting the dark version of doctor strange in some
of the trailer footage that doesn't happen until
way later episodes so during the first episode
you don't really get the full sense for how
everything's meant to be connected other than
jeffrey wright's version of the watcher sort of
narrating everything and serving as the backbone
for the continuity at least at the beginning of
the series the whole thing with episode three is
it also incorporates a lot of the events from the
marvel phase one movies like you see the avengers
forming but there's a very big twist on that it
also gets into some of what you see here with the
dead version of iron man from the events of iron
man 2 inside the donut shop it's kind of a murder
mystery episode that deals with the conceit what
if the avengers were murdered before they could
form and become the avengers like you see iron man
collapsed there with his coffee spilled as if he's
been murdered and you see nick fury in some of the
hydra agents like crossbones and the other hydra
agents from winter soldier carting black widow off
as if they're arresting her thinking that maybe
she's a suspect also during that episode there's
a really cool twist on the hulk so mark ruffalo
is back as his version of bruce banner hulk for
the entire series and it'll be a couple different
versions of the hulk because we're visiting a
bunch of different universes but at least this
first version of the hulk that we wind up seeing
because when this is happening this big murder
mystery about the avengers is during the events
of marvel phase one when we're still introducing
the characters it's actually mark ruffalo doing
some of the plot from the incredible hulk movie
so it's mark ruffalo doing a version of edward
norton's incredible hulk if you think about it
even though they're meant to be the same character
it already has a lot of multiverse alternate
timeline meta energy getting to the whole loki of
it all with kang in the multiverse war the sacred
timeline changing timelines like the joke that we
should blame he who remains kang for messing with
the sacred timeline and that's the reason edward
norton's hulk turned into mark ruffalo's hulk
like the changing timelines is the reason for the
recasting each of the episodes is meant to feel
like a big marvel movie but as the episodes go on
the same way that they paced out the loki episodes
the wand division episodes the falcon winter
soldier episodes things get crazier and crazier
with each new episode like crazier twists bigger
conceits that's why the marvel zombies of it all
which is probably one of the craziest things they
do during the series doesn't happen until the way
later episodes when you get up to the events of
avengers infinity war in the whole ultron of it
all ultron assembling all six infinity stones
and taking vision's body but if you spotted any
new easter eggs in the footage that i didn't talk
about in the video or you have big questions about
what's happening with the different versions of
the characters or how everything's going to work
and the continuity just write it below in the
comments and i'll add it to my episode 1 video
when i post that tomorrow everyone click here to
learn what's going on with spiderman during the
marvel what if episodes and click here for more
marvel what if episode 1 footage and easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you in the next video!